hi everyone I'm Ilana or Charl Amazon
and welcome to my channel and today I am
finally talking about where I'm moving
so some of you may have already heard me
mention it in previous videos and I
talked about it a whole bunch on social
media that I am moving countries and a
lot of you have guessed that yes I am
moving to America in like six days I am
so so unprepared for this I'll be living
in California but traveling pretty much
constantly for example I'm actually
flying into Atlanta first because
there's these smite World Championships
on so I'll be there and then at the end
of January I'll be going to pax South so
I'm gonna be kind of all over the place
all the time but because of this of
course means that I am leaving my Isle
of the Australian subscribers I thought
that I would do a giveaway for you guys
today
Thank You Australia for being awesome
and giving me an amazing start and I
guess really this opportunity to
actually move my career overseas
successfully that's it's that's crazy so
I'm gonna be doing the same job that I
do now which is hosting a web TV show
called button mash and I'm gonna
basically just be doing it over there I
don't know I'm not nervous and I'm not
excited yet I'm really worried about the
call don't know if you can tell that I'm
currently some but as hell because it's
still summer here in Australia so you
know but really I'm like red almost as
red as that lady what is she even doing
nailed it so I'm giving you some free
stuff now because this is meant to be
more of a like a thank you than an
actual competition all you need to do to
enter is tell me what the thing is that
you want of the things I'm about to show
you and what the easiest way to contact
you is I need to get these sent out
before I go so if you read Facebook
messages has to be your other inbox or
you won't see it then list that if you
prefer that I DM you on Twitter because
you'll get a notification or I can
message you on tumblr or direct message
you on Instagram whatever you want tell
me about a social network and I will
contact you on it so here's what I have
for y'all we have a three copies of a
Hyrule historia this is basically a
Zelda encyclopedia but I prefer to call
it the Zelda Bible because I know that
loads of you have come from the stuff
that I used to do on Zelda universe so I
was specifically like well why don't I
do
I roll the story that seems like a super
good idea I have a whole bunch of magic
together in cards now these are actually
not all necessarily ball of the Gods
these are cards
I don't use anymore so they're all
current but this is the only part of the
competition where things are going to
actually be secondhand and that's
actually just because a lot of people
want my magic gathering video asked if I
can send them stuff so if you want magic
you got it and last but not least is the
air force Z 60s at PC gaming headset I
have three of these again fully sealed
has not been opened at all and these
both being the first ever PC gaming
headset to feature in DTS headphone x so
that's pretty fancy they'll also work on
Mac because it's a USB connection and on
mobile devices because it's a 3.5
millimeter audio jet so those are pretty
sweet and y'all are gonna get some I
know I put up making this video for a
really long time because there's some
destiny stuff that I was supposed to get
from Activision that never actually
arrived so if that stuff arrives before
I leave then I will post it on social
media and hold like a separate
competition for that stuff which was
supposed to include a limited edition
copy on the ps4 and a whole bunch of
codes for the dock below and of course I
will come back to Australia I hope to
make it to pax Australia and to EB Expo
and I'm hosting Haven and Makai so
there's plenty of little conventions I'm
also guessing out so there's definitely
reasons for me to come back plenty so
another thing that I should mention is
that along with my move it's going to be
harder for me to make youtube videos I
mean it's already really hard I study
full-time and work full-time and have
several side jobs so it's pretty rough
but now I'm gonna be traveling even more
and further distances and living out of
home what I'm going to attempt if you
guys are interested in it please let me
know is making more vlogs that would be
way easier for me to produce and means
that I can still your regular stuff like
every time I go to a convention which is
really cool also means I get to show my
Australian subscribers what it's like
working as media at American conventions
which I'm really excited about but I
haven't really done many vlogs before or
no real vlogs I do stuff like this where
I told you guys but I haven't really
done a kind of day in the life of the
style vlog which is what this would be
so if you guys don't want me to do that
and you hate them or whatever tell me
that's cool and I'll figure out if
people would actually want to see those
on them but of course I shall do my best
and I think that wraps it up but that is
it for me today everyone I'm Alana thank
you guys for watching hopefully I will
see some of my American subscribers at
American conventions within the next
year which is going to be amazed
and I look forward to sending some of
you Australians some cool stuff okay I'm
done
I'll see you guys next time